الناس يزدادون ثراءً في تعدين
العملات المشفرة ، إن dhruvask شغوف جدًا بعملة البيتكوين
، وقد سمح لها بالاستيلاء على منزله ،
هذا الضجيج الأبيض لعامل التعدين المشفر ، ولم
أفلت
منه أبدًا ،
لقد أمضى عامل منجم العملة المشفرة على YouTube السنوات القليلة الماضية في
ملء منزله في فيرجينيا بأجهزة التعدين هذه
مصمم خصيصًا لكشف عملات البيتكوين الجديدة عن
طريق إجراء
حسابات
رياضية لا نهاية لها ودعم الشبكة من خلال الموافقة على
المعاملات لقد استنفدت إعدادي الكهربائي في
مزرعة تعدين المرآب الخاصة بي ،
أنا صديق مع جاري المجاور ،
أنا مثل مرحبًا يا رجل  سأضيف
بعض الكهرباء إلى الطابق السفلي الخاص
بك بمجرد سداد الكهرباء للمعدات الخاصة بك ،
وهي أكبر تكلفة تبلغ
فاتورة vosk الشهرية حوالي ألف
دولار الآن مع ارتفاع سعر البيتكوين 700
في عام
، كما يقول إن الأمر يستحق ذلك ، فأنا أجني حوالي
تعدين يوميًا  cryptocurrency وهو مع
الأجهزة
التي ربما كانت في السابق تقول
مثل 50
60 في اليوم ، لطالما كانت عملة البيتكوين
كثيفة الاستخدام للطاقة ، يمكنك رؤية القوة  من
عمال المناجم في مزرعة البيتكوين الروسية هذه التي
زرتها
في أواخر عام 2017. صاخبة جدًا هنا
عاصف جدًا وبما أن سعر البيتكوين
قد ارتفع بشكل كبير منذ ذلك الحين
فقد أصبح أكثر وأكثر
ربحية للتعدين وهذا يعني
المزيد من استهلاك الطاقة ديجي اقتصادي
موقع على شبكة الإنترنت  الذي يتتبع تقديرات استخدام طاقة البيتكوين ،
فإنه يستخدم الآن أكثر من بلجيكا
في عام ،
لديك شبكة
تستهلك بالفعل نصف بالمائة من
الاستهلاك العالمي للكهرباء ، ويمكننا أن
نتوقع أن يتضاعف هذا الرقم
بينما لا يزال غير قادر على تقديم
حتى أصغر جزء من  سكان العالم ،
لا يمكنهم سوى إجراء خمس
معاملات في الثانية
، على النقيض من ذلك ، يمكن لشبكة الدفع الخاصة بالتأشيرة أن
تتعامل مع أكثر من
65000 معاملة في الثانية ، وهو
تناقض لاحظه وزير الخزانة
جانيت يلين
في حدث نيويورك تايمز الأخير ، إنه
طريقة غير فعالة للغاية لإجراء
المعاملات
والمبلغ  من الطاقة المستهلكة
في
معالجة تلك المعاملات ،
تظهر الأبحاث المذهلة أن معظمها  من هذه الطاقة
عبارة عن وقود أحفوري
وفقًا لمركز كامبريدج
للتمويل البديل هذا الشهر ، يحدث
65 من تعدين البيتكوين في
الصين
التي يهيمن عليها الفحم ، ومع ذلك ، بينما
تبحث شركات التعدين في جميع أنحاء العالم عن
أرخص طاقة ، فإن
بعضها يضرب على مصادر متجددة مثل
مقاطعة كندا الكندية  كيبيك مدعومًا
بالكامل تقريبًا من السدود الكهرومائية
، كان هذا النوع من الاندفاع نحو الذهب لدينا
في عام 2018 حوالي 300
شركة اتصلت بنا أو راسلتنا رغبتها في
الحصول على الطاقة
استجابةً لحكومة المنطقة
التي أوقفت مشاريع تعدين العملات المشفرة
الجديدة وقدمت مجموعة مختارة  تتطلع العملية في
فيرجينيا
دروفاس أيضًا إلى مصادر الطاقة المتجددة ، وهدفه هو
تشغيل عملية التعدين بالكامل
باستخدام الألواح الشمسية الخاصة به ، إذا كان لا يزال
لديك بعض الألواح الشمسية على سطح منزلك ،
يمكنك التنقيب
عن الطاقة اللامركزية المجانية مقابل المال اللامركزي ،
وهو حل مستدام لطاقة البيتكوين
المتزايدة  مشكلة
كلير سيباستيان CNN نيويورك